this is the prince who wanted everything
it's another by Carens Jason okay so
this is they say if you like a get the
sound this one lumpy Space Princess has
kidnapped the Ice King what's a twist
and forces him to read the story of the
the lumpy Space Prince which of course
goes into you know the the that takes up
most of the episode which is the lumpy
Space Prince who has a totally different
voice than lumpy Space Princess and is
the guy from a show on the dead and show
on the dead he was the revenge on the
dead and so pretty there was something
doesn't matter holy cow yeah another
Romanian Jon the bed and that doesn't
like the parents so he decides to go off
and well remember the parents want him
to widdle his teeth down yeah get up
shot worms yeah eat worms
yeah and so they go and he goes into the
art world comes across Fionna and cake
and wants to make everybody his minions
but they say no dude knock it off and he
likes the peasant life so he gets used
to it and sure enough when the parents
come back and want him to return they
try to fight them off and he realizes
the best way to fight a mob is just to
not care so he shouts I don't care and
sure enough they eventually disappear
and then he's supposed to come into
another reality you lumpy Space Princess
is reality and you know be with her
forever but instead it's a possum who
bites her and then goes up ice Kings
robe and what just guess where it goes
from there big possum is a new being rat
night of terror so mad rising lino
imagine the girl in the sleeping bag
like the two people out there watching
this they have seen this with just me I
go my god
bread bread yeah he'll be one of them
it's a Bruna Matane movie Oh get soaked
our season all right long because they
hit their breakeven more people talked
about come Friday it's like it's
incredible
so yeah it's uh I liked it the only
thing that every single time I see one
of these now it's because I do really
like the Fionna cake concept I always
want to see more of the world and what
different people and creatures look like
and so I always get really impatient
like when it starts with the lumpy Space
Prince okay okay yeah yeah moon roll on
come on Lee see what all the other
people like you know oh there's magic
woman that's cool what's another one uh
you know a cinnamon bun at awesome let's
see what else we got
um so I get really impatient at the same
time I did I liked the voice work of the
lumpy Space Prince I thought he was kind
of funny I like the weird anime ish eyes
they gave him half the time which is
probably overplayed don't get me wrong
they probably do it too much but it just
always made me laugh I felt was funny I
liked how I even went through the hair
you know you can see it through the hair
I like the close-up of the tear and
stuff you know uh so that that made me
laugh um and yeah I think if he wasn't
that likable or the voice acting wasn't
that funny probably wouldn't worked as
well but because he was he still got a
good chunk of Fionna cake in there I
liked it okay I also liked how cake
always pointed out stuff and it never
made sense like how do you know your
name don't see the head to say
you know I thought that was like but I I
would like to see more of them because I
don't it's just fun to see what they
would you know it's fun to see them do
Finn and Jake stuff but from you know a
different gender and Jessi it's like Oh
does that you know would they do this
different or how would they do it
different they were sides it's fun to me
but I dug it I liked it I thought it was
really cute
I wanted more cake yes I always loved
working figuratively and literally yeah
oh such a nervous laugh
I wasn't quite as impatient as you I'm
not gonna lie I just desperately wanted
to pause and see everybody as it came
around I feel like I didn't get to see
absolutely everybody flameprince looked
really cool from what I could see and um
uh miss cupcake I guess had a rack on
her and I was like so distracted by her
rack out oh I didn't see anybody else
damnit so I can see why you wanted more
kick double D cupcake you know what I
mean
it was cute at first I was like oh
really I was actually honestly confused
because I had assumed wrongfully so that
this you know because it's fanfic and
all that as I go so LSP has like a tiny
little crush on Finn what's this about I
don't know that I like this but I
thought it was really cute in the end
that it was like well she kind of
emulates thin a little bit you know with
the oh I want to be poor and stuff but
you can tell she kind of thinks there's
something cool about Finn but then it
was funny because in the end it was all
the whole point of it was that no one
was as awesome as her and so she wanted
this Prince to come from the parallel
universe to be as awesome with her so I
thought that was pretty cute that was it
I wasn't as excited about this I mean I
was but it was like it's okay I think
it's another case of too much LSP if
that makes sense
for me though it wasn't the voice the
voice work was great it was freaking
hilarious but I just do was okay you
know the one thing before Jason talks
because his is always the least
important is that whenever they do these
I always have to remind myself oh yeah
these are fanfiction so they have to be
written like the person who wrote it you
know with that and
mine so the last one you know was
Marceline so it's very much gonna be
kind of started around her and her story
and so on and then this one's lumpy
Space Princess so it has to sort of be
turned around her and what would she
write in there you know where the first
one was Ice King and it's which was so
bizarre but he's so bizarre so it kind
of makes it okay and there's Franco's on
the one hand it's neat looking at from
that point of view but on the other hand
I think the Fionna and cake world is so
enjoyable and so funny that I do it's
one of the few times where I do kind of
want to say screw the continuity just
just show us more video to just let the
world kind of you are odd I mean for me
I join so much and I enjoy the variation
that it's like I would like just to see
the world
not necessarily told by a different
person or a lie just like Ice King tell
it again me I don't know but yeah that's
always a tough aspect you have to juggle
in there and you're just done this was
bad fanfic written by a bad family like
the thing is this the fanfic was ice
King's the only reason why Marceline
took over was because it's just like
you're doing it wrong let me just tell
you and listening the whole time now it
is someone who has taken the fanfic
world and written their own fanfic
around the fanfic world and that's to me
just how I felt about this level
entirely it was just so bottom of the
barrel
I love the voice actor I yeah I loved
him in Shaun of the Dead and his voice
but it's like I'm so done with Fionna
and cake the initially from one I
remember the reason why they did Fionna
and cake is because they were mocking
fanfic they were kind of saying haha
before you guys start doing this stuff
we're gonna do it and get it out of the
way now we're getting an episode every
single season and it's like oh so you
don't like fanfic but you're just gonna
keep encouraging it more and more and
more and now you're just having I don't
know I wish it was an episode devoted to
Finn and Jake you know not another
Fionna and cake episode I liked the Ice
King in the beginning with the nod to
misery I did like that
that was funny there's not much else
like I just didn't care you were saying
about taking prisoners whatever you were
saying about how lumpy Space Princess
likes
Finn well yeah obviously if you up stuff
said made out yeah so but I just you
know I thought that was just part of
like the goofy episode thing this I
liked that in the end it turned out that
she was still more in love with herself
yeah kind of what I thought it just was
more in character right that's Plus also
on top of that I'm sorry I thought I
thought it was a bit too well-written to
be coming from lumpy space yeah sorry
some of the things in there it's like no
that's nothing like you would write well
that's always the interesting juggle
like even with Ice King a lot of that
stuff you sort of go
wait you know you wouldn't write better
even Marceline it's like doing
necessarily you know write that stuff in
that off Naruto or don't knock it that's
what you're doing actually I kind of
would disagree when it comes to the Ice
King if you look they he had volumes and
volumes and volumes and volumes of you
know Fionna and cake stuff so I think by
the point and time we finally got to
hear one Hitler find his writing style I
think he gets all all his creativity and
everything through his writing I think
it actually kind of works and Marceline
being as old as she is I think she could
change with it and go oh I mostly won
what's the least unrealistic you know
that seem to make this man honestly
thought I I was doing this one
surprisingly more than the the Marceline
one or the Mars what marshalese
Marceline yeah I dug this a little bit
more than that because I thought there
was a few more laughs in it you know
and I did like watching that lumpy space
Prince strangely enough cuz he was just
you know I I think because of a voice
work at the strange animation on him um
where even though I do like the Marshall
leave one else or saying like you know
okay well this is kind of like you sit
just sort of the fanfiction of these two
you know will there be a romance or not
um and yeah I don't know it's like I
should like the Marshall Lee one more
but for some reason I think that I think
a lot of it is just the voice work on
this guy and the way he's written but I
I'd be lying as I didn't know what you
were talking about with the whole fan
fiction thing um and I'd like to stink
this for like the record I'm fine with
fanfic when I was a kid I did fanfic as
well but that was also 20 plus years ago
when you mock fanfic don't keep coming
back to it because then you were just
kind of counteracting what you were
saying to begin with well for me it
seems more like instead of it like it
might start an offensive fanfic but he
was so good and so funny that it sort of
took on a life of its own you know so I
did to me whenever they do another one
it's not as much as hey were just
mocking fanfic it's more hey we're
having more fun with this world but
again that gets to the tricky the tricky
area with like you know lumpy Space
Princess wrote this one you have to stay
true that it's fanfiction you know so
you have to really focus on this one
area but on the other hand you're right
it's way too well-written to be there's
something she would write if something
really neat more gotcha time lumpy Space
Princess for Prince the Prince was fine
I dug the brown sorry he was funny I
thought it was pretty funny um but yeah
I mean it's I mean I do get the feeling
like I probably at most I could take one
more specific vo yeah I know you're done
and probably rightfully so don't getting
rides a total selfish thing do I see
another one cuz I know the next one will
probably be really bad and I'll be like
oh god they should have stopped but it's
like I'm still just so damn curious
because I like I said I just like the
variation I like you say when they
flying through it's like I want to pause
and see the
different ones that they didn't maybe
that's it maybe I want to see more of
the characters and their interactions I
don't necessarily want just focus on one
or two throughout the whole thing I want
to see more of like just a bunch of the
characters together and maybe that's
partially what it is for me is that the
first two they did they did you actually
saw stuff going on at the parties like
you saw them dancing you saw a bit a bit
more interaction not a ton but you
definitely some more and this one was
just kind of like to me it felt like
we're gonna cram in as many of these
characters as we can so you can be like
oh look there's blank and blank and
blank and blank and blank and blank and
blank and bike and it's like it felt
cheap like it just it there was and
again I know it's bad fed fanfic based
off a fanfic like why were all the
princes there it kind of didn't really
work I don't know it just didn't work
for me I don't know and I've spelled
cheap and I like the look of them but it
didn't feel natural and I know it's
stupid talking about a fanfic episode
you know I I will say like when they had
a bunch of the the prisoners there and
they had that wasn't flameprince
yeah there and I was thinking myself
what I love to actually know what
flameprince is like in this universe I
love to know you know how things worked
out you know cuz even then it's like
things don't necessarily work out
exactly how it did in you know in the
real world you know but yeah it's like I
like to know well what exactly is his
story then and how did this work out and
yeah I don't know I I think I would like
I said it's a very mix of what's gonna
be a good story and good characters and
just what I want to see and what I want
to see is all these different characters
interact off each other which is why I
think you're right I think the party
atmosphere of the last two was a bit
more clever but yeah I still got a good
okay I'm sure they made a fourth one I
wouldn't like it but you never know so
well let's let's take bets right now
since there will be another one I can
pretty much guarantee it let's let's
think about now
who is going to be the next one about so
that the one the one who writes it I
mean I wonder who it's because like okay
Marceline kind of wrote it kind of did
she just kind of created her own right
down in there so it's kind of like okay
you had you know Finn and Jake first one
then he had why he's game technically
but yeah but what I'm saying it focus
run Finn and Jake yeah okay fair enough
Finn and Jake Marsha Marceline and then
now lumpy Space Princess who do you
think the next one is going to be about
or based around what main characters I I
would probably say Flame Princess would
do like the main one cuz I'm sure people
so it's like flame prince what's Flame
Princess
you know it kind of like what I was
saying uh but if not I think they just
do something batshit insane and do like
cinnamon bun or something actually my
guess I was gonna go a cinnamon bun one
step lower than lumpy Space Princess
well I don't know I only saw him briefly
when he was actually smart well I'm
gonna go my guess is hmm know the
character hmm I'm gonna go with
bubblegum an entire episode around
bubblegum
but tell me Moll did we get that before
the first one day that was long he was a
background character morning or a
secondary character mommy you look so
pretty it was about that is kind of
right I mean we do spend a lot of time
you know with him and Fiona and Matt so
I mean it but the episode was about
Fionna and cake and you're following
gumball and I pee be too repetitive oh
no no I'm just saying I that's my guess
I'm gonna go gumball okay Joey any
guesses really no it's like I don't know
it's just it's gonna be the Daleks from
the Doctor Who oh yeah every season
we're gonna have one and
that's okay because their fan favorite
and and there's nothing wrong with them
but the more seasons you go the more
it's like okay wait a shoehorn them in
yeah you know I think it's more fun when
it seems to fit I think this is the time
where it starts feeling like oh Lord
another Dalek episode okay well at least
let's get this over with so we can get
through the rest of the season sort of
missing that's what I'm saying it didn't
feel it felt like they have you're
completely right it feels like they have
to do a female Fionna and cake episode
every season see I'll say I felt that
with the last one anyway so I'm just
sort of like okay let's just enjoy this
bride is my thought you're not good when
I saw the opening was kinda like hey
like you know let's see what they do um
it like I say cuz I just like the
variety of it well okay see how they've
done three times now but you know what I
mean you know seeing the different
characters I'm learning more about it
actually I want to change my guest I'm
gonna go with B Mel B Mel B in my - you
said it's going to be B Mel because
BMO's just be Momo would create a story
and I could actually see BMO kind of
going around ooh
seeing other people kind of a that'd be
great yeah just say yeah or like she'll
be you know kind of like this -
background character it's kind of like
going around of doing their daily
business like Shelby goes into a you
know a store and there's you know you
cinnamon bun at talking with you know
gumball and talking with you know three
trunk er I don't know the male treats
their throats yes like just then have
those three interacting and then after
that's kind of done Shelby goes into
another area where beemo does III think
he won't be a good idea because she
technically has no gender yeah seems to
go back and forth and she would be
exactly the same
yeah no that won't be that I like that I
deal a lot I would really
like that too like that just seeing them
interact cuz that's really what I want
to see yes yeah I'd enjoyed that because
it would be again I think it's also the
whole point that it focused on lumpy
Space Princess yeah I always kind of a
yeah like I still liked it but at the
same time it's like yeah I want to just
be in this world
let me just the first one really seemed
to do well at letting you just sort of
accept this concept you know and have
fun with it and the second one was like
okay but it was definitely like I said
I'm starting to feel like okay I'm sure
they did this cuz they felt they had to
mhm and this one I felt the same I just
thought it was funnier you know I got
more laughs out of it so emotionally
much better yeah because it's also
possibly because you liked Marshall Lee
over lumpy Space Prince like Marceline
is more likable no I'm done with this
like like lumpy Space Prince said I
don't care what's that lumpy Space
Princess our own Schwarzenegger put a
cookie down now we to do matter so does
that mean your parents will disappear
one can only go I'm okay with that dark